when Donald Trump selected Matthew
Whitaker to be his acting Attorney
General after Jeff Sessions was forced
out we knew that there were endless
problems with this we knew about
Whitakers previous comments about how if
he were in a position to influence the
Robert Moeller Trump Russia
investigation
he has very specific ideas for how he
would starve it of funds in order to
prevent it from happening effectively
we've talked about how Matthew Whitaker
is on the record previously as publicly
saying he believes that the entire Trump
Russia investigation by Robert Muller is
an overreach from a legal perspective
and so where we kind of came to where we
ended up in terms of our conclusions was
that Matthew Whitaker had no business
whatsoever being acting Attorney General
for even an hour never mind a few months
but ultimately he remained in that
position and continues to be in it today
until Attorney General Barr is
presumably confirmed at some point
relatively soon so that gets us to
Friday on Friday
Whitaker testified before the House
Judiciary Committee and it was such a
gong show of embarrassment for all that
is good and logical in the world and I'm
gonna play some clips for you here we're
going to start with congressman Jerry
Nadler who asks a really simple question
which was have you ever been asked to
approve any request or action to be
taken by the special counsel and his
answer was congressman your time is up
and you will actually hear the room
audibly gasp and groan at this answer
from Matthew Whitaker take a look at
this in your capacity as acting Attorney
General have you ever been asked to
approve any requests or action to be
taken by the special counsel mr.
Chairman I see that your five minutes is
up and so
we we we we I am me I'm here voluntarily
we have agreed to five-minute rounds
committee I think that's a fine place
the end the five-minute rule you can't
use the fact that your testimony is
voluntary as a reason not to answer and
if anything that's a reason to subpoena
this guy right away and get answers to
these questions and then in comes
congressman David Cicilline from Rhode
Island and he starts getting into it
with Whitaker and it goes just as poorly
take a look you were briefed by the
special counsel you've acknowledged that
did you share that information with any
members of your staff the information
you learned in that briefing from the
special counsel or his team congressman
as I previously testified there was one
other individual in that briefing with
and who is that individual it is the US
attorney from the Eastern District of
California who I've brought on what is
the name of the individual mr. Whitaker
his name is Greg Scott so that's the did
you communicate any information you
learned in those briefings to other
members of your staff I don't believe so
no so that you understand those slow
answers those pauses from Whitaker are
because at the beginning of his five
minutes congressman Cicilline said I
have limited time I don't need you to
thank me for my questions I don't need
you to say the questions or good just
answer the questions and then Whitaker
adopted this strategy of just pausing
for a few seconds before each answer and
it kept going and it was just as bad do
you know whether any information that
you learned and those briefings were
communicated to anyone at the White
House as I mentioned previously
congressman we have kept a very close
mr. Whitaker it's a yes or a No do you
know whether it was commuted to anybody
at the White House as I see here today I
don't I don't I don't know whether it
was communicated you know any
restrictions or limitations or
instructions to your staff not to share
this information with anyone at the
White House or the president's legal
team yes together with the general
standard that investigative information
and materials are need-to-know and law
enforcement thank you mr. Whitaker dude
you've got to hand it to him I mean he's
doing a great job of eating up as much
of those
minutes as possible without really
saying anything let's continue to the
third clip
did the president lash out at you after
Michael Cohen's guilty plea for lying to
Congress about a Trump organization
project to build a tower in Moscow the
president specifically tweeted that he
had not laughed I did I'm asking you mr.
Whittaker did the president lash out at
you not asking what he tweeted I don't
have a lot of confidence in the veracity
of his tweets I'm asking you under oath
congressman that is based on an
unsubstantiated sir answer the question
yes or no did the president lash out to
you about mr. Cohen's guilty plea no he
did not
and did anyone from the White House or
anyone on the president's behalf lash
out at you no so then we get into a
really good logic pretzel on January
22nd congressman Nadler sent Whittaker a
letter with questions that Democrats
might ask him during exactly these
hearings that were watching about his
conversations with Donald Trump and in
the letter but Nadler tells Whittaker
consult with the White House ahead of
time about whether Donald Trump would
invoke executive privilege over those
questions
allowing Whittaker not to answer without
simply refusing to answer this is really
key Cicilline asks Whittaker whether he
showed the questions to the White House
and Whittaker says that he didn't so
thus if Whittaker hasn't shown the
questions to the White House there'd be
no way to assert privilege and it gets
really confusing and then Whittaker just
won't answer whether or not he's
actually spoken to Donald Trump about
the Moller or any other investigation
into him which of course he shouldn't be
doing did you walk share the questions
that mr. Nadler forwarded to you prior
to this hearing with anyone at the White
House or the president's legal counsel
um congressman I did not so when you
claimed earlier that you are going to
invoke a privilege you voguing your
privilege about questions the president
hasn't even seen congressman to be clear
I'm not invoking any privilege
well you said earlier that you and your
written testimony that you would not
answer questions about your
conversations with the president did you
not yes I do you are not sitting
here today saying the president has
instructed you not to answer a question
correct I am NOT sitting here today
saying that the president hasn't so then
you're prepared to answer all these
questions congressman I think I was
pretty explicit in my opening statement
so have you spoken to the president mr.
Whitaker about the Muller investigation
congressman as I have previously
testified I had did not talk talked to
the president about the more of us have
you ever spoken to the President or
members or parts of his legal team about
information that you've learned in your
capacity as acting attorney general
related to the mother investigation or
any other criminal investigation
involving the president congressman
while I have specifically been saying
that I'm not going to comment about my
conversations with the president or his
senior staff I have also been very clear
that the president has not instructed me
to do anything I said that wasn't my
question my question is have you had
conversations about what you learned
that's a yes or no congressman I have I
spend all day every day twisting
Whitaker my questions very specific have
you spoken to the president or his legal
team about what you've learned in the
Muller investigation or were the related
criminal investigations that may involve
the president yes or no congressman as I
specifically answered earlier two of the
what you're clearly not gonna answer the
question so I'm gonna move on yeah so we
don't get any further with that and then
the cherry on top pad is that after the
hearing Whitaker was spotted at Trump
International Hotel in Washington DC
when you watched this does this guy
strike you as honest and forthcoming and
transparent well I'm glad he's just the
acting Attorney General and I think
compared to this guy William Barr is
going to do a lot better it's not easy
to obstruct justice I mean the president
has struggled with that continually over
the past couple years and Whitaker
didn't do too well either no certainly
not and we will see ultimately what the
day is where Attorney General future
attorney general Barr takes over one of
the days sponsors is privacy calm slash
Pakman which is a free service that I
myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card to privacy calm
then you can create virtual credit cards
that are linked directly to your bank
account and you use those virtual credit
card numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the Internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a David
Pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy com icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy comm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link